michael jackson's kids look grown up
that's paris and prince jackson making a
rare appearance for the opening night of
mj the musical a broadway show about
their late father
the 23 year old actress rocks a paisley
printed midi dress while her brother
sports a suit and tie also there their
younger brother blanket who goes by bg
now bg chose not to walk the carpet with
his older siblings but was seen exiting
the theater donning a suit just like his
big bro check out the trio leaving hand
in hand
paris also shared behind the scenes
moments from the show like this photo
with prince this shot showing off her
outfit and a pic with her cousin tj
jackson michael's brother tito's son
[Music]
now what's mj the musical about the king
of pop duh
the show tells the story of mj played by
miles frost in the early 90s ahead of
his dangerous world tour
[Music]
and as michael's legacy continues to
thrive his kids are surely making him
proud that's just kind of what each of
us want to do and kind of makes things
that people hopefully enjoy but also can
benefit their lives in november bg gave
a rare interview to good morning britain
there's a lot of really cool stuff here
i think
there's a lot of history in this house
and the studio here that's what he was
all about and that's just kind of what
each of us want to do and kind of makes
things that people hopefully enjoy but
also can benefit their lives and when it
comes to their family bond prince says
it's never been stronger any moment that
i get to spend with my siblings now
especially as we're getting older you
know and our own lives are starting to
kind of blossom and grow
every moment that i get with them any
little family dinner any family outing
is really a special moment for me and
the jackson kids careers are going full
steam ahead prince graduated from loyola
marymount university in 2019 and shared
his goals with e.t i feel that my time
is best devoted to the non-profit right
now because that's where my passion lies
i still have a creative bug and i'm
figuring out how i'm fitting into the
entertainment industry and paris she's
already found her spot following in her
famous dad's footsteps as a singer
[Music]
and she's got a booming acting career i
just want to be able to operate my own
machinery every captain should know how
to steer her own ship that's paris
latest flick hulu's sex appeal and when
e.t caught up with the actress she
gushed over all the support she's gotten
from family and friends i think it's
super important i mean like as
a species we're very social creatures
we've always lived in communities and
tribes it's just very very important
like isolation can do a number on your
mental health and things like that so
having support i've especially in the
last few years like i've gotten more
comfortable surrounding myself with
women
because i grew up with a single father
and like three brothers so like
i wasn't really around a lot of women in
the last few years i've um developed a
very strong meaningful relationships
with with very graceful women around me
and
um being surrounded by that has had a
huge impact on my mental health and just
feeling good about myself and just you
know having my girls with me
you